[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales del
programa de france 24 que los invita a
dar una vuelta al mundo de la mano de
nuestra red de periodistas ucrania lanzó
una contraofensiva en el sur del país
con el objetivo de hacer retroceder a
las tropas rusas en ejercer la primera
región en caer en manos de moscú al
inicio de la guerra quien asegura estar
cosechando los primeros frutos con la
toma de algunas localidades mientras que
las autoridades prorrusas que controlan
la zona pausaron sus planes de adelantar
un referendo en la región tal y como
hicieron en crimea en el año 2014 el
testimonio de un paracaidista ruso está
dando de qué hablar tras arremeter
públicamente contra vladimir putin y
denunciar la guerra en ucrania que
considera un sinsentido para güelfi
latif estaba hasta hace unas semanas
combatiendo en ucrania hasta que decidió
huir de su país para pedir asilo en
francia el siguiente es un reportaje de
nuestros compañeros de foster
tras llegar al baño del aeropuerto de
parís-charles de gaulle el primer gesto
de papel filial fue simbólico lo
recomiendo
aquí están mis papeles mi cartilla
militar rusa basura
por mi pasaporte ruso basura
amo a rusia y a mis compatriotas rusos
pero putin y el gobierno no son rusia
putin vete al infierno
a las 48 horas en un centro de detención
el joven de 34 años ahora considerado un
desertor recibe permiso para entrar en
francia y está trabajando con un abogado
para obtener el estatus de asilado su
testimonio arremete contra la guerra del
presidente vladimir putin y ucrania mata
boston
los rusos y los ucranianos nos matamos
entre nosotros pero también matamos
civiles muchos civiles no podía aceptar
lo que estaba pasando y vamos a un
pueblo y lo destruyamos todo está preso
y ahora salut la grada
soldado de élite estaba dispuesto a
morir por su país pero tras dos meses de
guerra en el frente consideró que la
invasión no tenía sentido
hoy en día muchos soldados rusos se
niegan completamente a ir a la guerra y
los que van no tienen motivación por eso
putin nada de recluir a los prisioneros
y a los ancianos está muerto vale nada
al cine desde whites tras ser herido en
combate comenzó a escribir sus
experiencias mientras estaba en el
hospital hablando de la desorganización
del ejército ruso y de las matanzas
irracionales un sitio web de su país
publicó extractos para su red y el canal
de youtube de un grupo defensor de los
derechos humanos le invito a hablar
solo quiero que la gente vea la verdad y
los hechos cuando encienda la televisión
oigan a rusia- decir que está librando a
ucrania de los nazis me he enterado de
que mi mando ha pedido una condena de 15
años contra mi acusándome de difamar al
ejército fue una razón suficiente para
huir me convertí en una amenaza para
ellos
temiendo por su vida pasó un mes fugado
antes de ser ayudado a salir a
escondidas por los denunciantes tras
llegar a francia hace unos días piensa
pedir asilo y protección policial
italia es el primer productor europeo de
tomates también es el primer productor
mundial de derivados de tomate en
conserva pero este año este sector está
en peligro entre la sequía y los costos
de producción que se han disparado desde
el comienzo de la guerra en ucrania el
rendimiento está en caída libre el
siguiente es un reportaje de louis
manual y lorenza pensado
la cosecha de tomate comienza temprano
por la mañana antes de que haga
demasiado calor y sea demasiado difícil
trabajar esta temporada se han
registrado temperaturas superiores a los
37 grados durante periodos inusualmente
largos
tuvimos que regar con mucha más
frecuencia cuando las temperaturas
alcanzaron los picos más altos porque la
planta perdía más agua lo habitual nos
adaptamos acortando los tiempos de riego
a pesar de sus esfuerzos giovanni
terrence yo ha perdido al menos un 20
por ciento de su producción esta es una
situación común para toda la región de
publio esta provincia del sur de italia
suele suministrar casi la mitad de la
producción de tomate del país
enviamos este representante del
sindicato local ha venido a evaluar la
situación
pero era puesto de cultivar lavó su
favor y alegato solo solo duda además de
la pérdida de frutos los costos de
producción son mucho más elevados debido
al alza de los precios de la energía
para producir una hectárea de tomates
antes nos gastábamos diez mil euros
ahora nos gastamos 15 mil cultivos 100
hectáreas así que si antes me costaba un
millón de euros ahora tengo que
adelantar 1.5 millones para producir esa
misma cantidad el estado les ha
concedido un crédito fiscal del 20 por
ciento en la compra de combustible una
ayuda insuficiente ya que los costos
adicionales siguen aún dando incluso en
las plantas de procesamiento donde el
precio de una botella de vidrio se ha
duplicado en un año
un kilo de tomates nos cuesta 30
céntimos y pagamos 23 céntimos por el
envase y 5 céntimos por la tapa esto
significa que el producto en sí y su
envase tienen casi el mismo precio lo
cual es absurdo absurdo
los representantes del sector del tomate
han solicitado ayuda urgente al estado
solo en la región de puglia 1500
empresas se encuentran en una situación
peligrosa
en españa la reforma migratoria del
gobierno ha supuesto un cambio de 180
grados para muchos inmigrantes que
actualmente se encuentran en el país sin
papeles con miras a aliviar la falta de
trabajadores ésta facilita la
posibilidad de adquirir los documentos
necesarios para trabajar entró en vigor
hace poco pero supone un alivio para
muchos el siguiente es un informe de
sarah morris es el insmet
santos tiene 48 años y es de brasil
lleva 5 años en españa sin documentación
oficial
intento luchar contra la burocracia por
sí solo pero finalmente acudió a una
abogada tratando buena salen buenas
noticias podría conseguir un permiso de
trabajo pronto siempre hay gente que
quiere pagarle la mitad o muchos menos
de la mitad por el mismo trabajo que
haría una persona que está regularizada
con estás nervioso mira uno para los
lados pues se puede pasar a alguien que
te piden documentación ar desde ahora
puedo dormir tranquilo muero mucho mejor
la última reforma migratoria del
gobierno ha simplificado los trámites
para que los migrantes indocumentados
que llevan dos años en españa consigan
sus papeles con la opción de la
residencia de arraigo por formación va a
poder ayudar a muchos extranjeros que se
encuentran actualmente situación
irregular ya que les está dando la
oportunidad de tener una residencia sin
necesidad de tener una oferta de trabajo
otro grupo que se beneficie de la
reforma son los estudiantes desde ahora
cuando finalicen sus estudios recibirán
automáticamente un año extra de visado
en españa un tiempo vital para conseguir
un trabajo
final con tanta burocracia y tanta
demora en resolver lo de los papeles da
la sensación de que las únicas opciones
que tiene es devolverte a tu país o
trabajar de forma ilegal ante la escasez
de trabajadores y una población cada vez
más envejecida españa ha tenido que
transformar su enfoque migratorio un
paso histórico según la fundación por
causa no solo regulariza a las personas
que ya están aquí sino que ofrece
posibilidades de regularización a
aquellas personas que vayan a venir por
lo tanto lo que hace es regularizar todo
el sistema y eso es era necesario y es
importantísimo y es una novedad
prácticamente en europa
actualmente se estima que medio millón
de extranjeros viven en españa sin
papeles
en israel decenas de miles de
solicitantes de asilo llegados de áfrica
sufren desprotección institucional su
situación irregular los expone a pobres
condiciones de trabajo y de vida
acompañadas de discriminación frente a
este vacío diversos grupos les brindan
asistencia y les ayudan en su
integración entre ellos la filial de un
club argentino que usa el fútbol como
herramienta informe de nuestros
corresponsables federico cue barberena y
yanira gómez muñoz
hace 7 años mucha llegó a israel huyendo
de la violencia en sudán en su travesía
de 16 días por el desierto del sinaí dos
de sus compañeros fueron asesinados al
cruzar la frontera las autoridades
israelíes lo encarcelaron seis meses en
s'agaró nim y un año en el centro de
detención a cielo abierto dejó lot antes
de ser liberado sin saber hebreo ni
tener permiso para trabajar o estudiar
no es que nos trataran de mala manera
pero fue muy difícil lidiar mentalmente
con la incertidumbre de no saber si te
van a enviar de vuelta a tu país o si te
van a dejar entrar desconfían de ti
entonces toda la ciudad que pide si
necesitas recibir no te la dan
es la realidad de más de 30.000
solicitantes de asilo en israel la
mayoría de sudaneses eritreos que sufren
un limbo legal solo desde hace semanas
mucha pertenece al menos del 1% que ha
recibido el estatus de refugiado en su
integración el fútbol y un equipo fueron
claves estudiantes
nacida hace cinco años en la filial
israelí del club argentino estudiantes
de la plata mucho de un grupo de amigos
a un equipo multicultural que junto a
dos ongs asiste y reúne todo tipo de
ayuda a refugiados
nosotros hecho combatimos las barreras
de los estigmas y los refugiados bueno
se encuentra con problemáticas como por
ejemplo no tienen un seguro social no
tienen la posibilidad de estudiar en
cualquier lugar como si podría por
ejemplo un inmigrante o un israelí
estamos ahí en todo eso para ayudarlos a
que salgan adelante bajo las órdenes del
entrenador de este conjunto de israelíes
inmigrantes latinoamericanos y
solicitantes de asilo de áfrica se
entrena cada jueves para competir en una
liga amateur una vez que te pones acá en
el césped entras a jugar no importa si
hablas un idioma a otro idioma en el
fútbol es como que su lenguaje aparte
se rompe esa barrera adentro de la
cancha se entiende por los otros
sectores es un lenguaje el espíritu de
la filial pasa de boca en boca y cada
vez más solicitantes de asilo buscan
seguir los pasos de musas que frente al
vacío institucional de israel encontró
un hogar dentro y fuera de la cancha
gracias por seguir un nuevo episodio de
corresponsales nos damos cita la próxima
semana siga con más información en
francés 24 dyn france24 punto com